so we're asked is the expression x minus
3 is this a factor of this fourth degree
polynomial and you could solve this by
doing algebraic long division by taking
all of this business and dividing it by
x minus 3 and figuring out if you have a
remainder if you if you do end up with a
remainder then this is not a factor of
of this but if you don't have a
remainder then that means that this
divides fully into this right over here
without a remainder which means it is a
factor so if the remainder is equal to
zero
the remainder is equal to zero if and
only if it's a factor it is a factor
and we know a very fast way of
calculating the remainder of when you
take some polynomial and you divide it
by a first degree expression like this i
guess you could say when you divide it
by a first degree polynomial like this
the polynomial remainder theorem the
polynomial remainder theorem tells us
that if we take some
let me do this some polynomial p of x
and we were to divide it by
some x minus a
then the remainder is just going to be
equal to
our polynomial
evaluated at
our polynomial evaluated at a so let's
just see what's a in this case well in
this case our a is positive 3. so let's
just evaluate our polynomial at x equals
if what we get is equal to 0 that means
our remainder is 0 and that means that x
minus 3 is a factor if we get some other
remainder that means well we have a
nonzero remainder and this isn't a
factor so let's try it out
so
we're going to have so i'm just going to
do it i'll do it all in magenta it might
be a little computationally intensive so
it's going to be two
times three to the fourth power three to
the fourth through the third is 81
minus 11 yeah this is this is going to
get a little computationally intensive
but let's let's see if we can power
through it 11 times
27 i probably should have picked a
simpler example but let's just keep
going plus 15
times 9
plus 4 times 3 is 12
minus 12. so lucky for us at least
stills last two terms cancel out
and so this is going to be the rest from
here is arithmetic 2 times 81 is 162.
now let's think about what 27 times 11
is so let's see 27 times 10 is going to
be 270
270 plus another 27 is minus 297
297 did i do that yeah 270 so 27 times
10 is 270 plus 27 297 yep that's right
and then
we have
i'm prone to make carol's hours here see
90 plus 45 is 135 so plus 135
and let's see if i were to take
if i were to take 162 and 135 that's
going to give me 297
minus 297
minus 200 that green color
minus
and we do indeed equal zero so the
remainder when i if i were to divide
this by this is equal to 0 so x minus 3
is indeed a factor of all of this
business